so a jew-hating congresswoman Ilan Omar
tweeted yesterday a standard
anti-semitic trope well actually that
was on that was on Sunday claiming that
the Jews over in Israel are paying off
Republicans buying their support this is
the same well you have to look at this
in the context of the sort of stuff that
this woman often says and tweets she
tweeted out a few years ago that Israel
has quote hypnotized the world and she
prayed that Allah would help us all see
the evil doings
of the Israelis so this is this is all
part of a pattern a pattern that you can
find throughout the Democratic Party
with anti-semitism and bigotry of all
different kinds bigotry in general is a
common theme in in the Democrat Party
this after all is the party that
subjects Christian judges to
unconstitutional religious tests
examining their belief systems and their
religious affiliations and convictions
as if that's somehow relevant to the to
what they're going to be doing you
remember one of the most bigoted
statements
I think uttered by an American
politician in recent memory was Dianne
Feinstein telling Amy Kony Barrett that
her Catholic dogma quote lives loudly
within her and that's a concern she said
so if you want to understand why that's
bigoted well then all you have to do is
imagine a Republican senator saying
something like that to a Muslim judicial
nominee and saying you know your Islamic
your Islamic faith lives loudly within
you and that's a concern now of course
in that context everybody would agree
and and the left would be calling it
Islamophobic and so on and so forth
senators Canella Harris and mazie Hirono
have have likewise scrutinized Christian
judges for their faith or or if they're
affiliated with you know the dastardly
Knights of Columbus
and this is nothing of course compared
to what Democrat politicians and
Democrat policies and state governments
do to Christian business owners who face
who face persecution penalties fines for
simply trying to operate and live
according to biblical precepts the
Democratic Party is also your one-stop
shop for man-hating
and anti white rhetoric and they've come
out against stay-at-home moms and you
know Midwesterners and southerners and
home schoolers and of course if we're
talking about bigotry among Democrats
there is no group more reviled more
diminished and discriminated against by
Democrats than the unborn who according
to nearly every single Democrat in the
country at every level of government
don't even count as people okay so when
you think about this it's it's really no
wonder that Democrats are constantly
trying to hang the bigot label around
other people's necks trying to call
other people bigots this is just a
classic case of projection that's all
you don't need to be a a psycho
therapists to see what's happening here
this it's very similar to the cheating
husband who becomes very suspicious of
his wife which because because he's
cheating he kind of sees that in
everybody else because that's how he is
there was a recent survey that was done
that that showed that a sizable majority
over 60% of registered Democrats think
that Republicans are bigoted and sexist
now keep in mind that many of these same
people think that babies aren't human
masculinity is toxic the Jewish state
has no right to exist Christians should
be forced to bake cakes for gay weddings
against their will so among other things
so they are so immersed in their
fanatical prejudices that they they
cannot see anything but prejudice in
others because that's just that's the
world they live in and this is no so
prai's really because that's how it is
with bigots all the time that that's how
bigots operate they never think that
their own bigotry counts right there are
very few bigots who will just admit oh
yeah yeah I'm a bigot short no the the
justification is always well known oh
yeah I'm allowed to hate those people
because they deserve it of course I can
hate them no it doesn't kind of if I'm
if I you know say something awful about
white man well that's okay cuz they
deserve it I'm allowed to say that in
fact that is that is literally the the
leftist philosophy that is their
theories of race and gender dynamics
exempt them from any charge of prejudice
or discrimination this is what they
believe this is what they are taught and
teach in college that essentially you
know it's impossible for for instance a
white man to be the victim of racism or
sexism you could treat him however you
want you can say whatever you want to
him it doesn't matter because his
institutional power insulates him from
bigotry or some such nonsense these
kinds of rationales allow their hatred
and their bigotry to go unchecked and
unnoticed but bigotry is still bigotry
and the Democratic Party is where it
thrives in our culture now you could you
could say that well you know if you go
to the far-right extreme end of the
spectrum you've got white nationalists
and racist over there and sure okay fine
a couple of differences though number
one that is a despite what you may hear
but from the media that is a pretty
small group and number two they are
denounced by everybody else on the right
nearly everybody certainly in the
mainstream you know white nationalism
has been has been denounced and any time
Republican or conservative says
something perceived as racist you're
going to have other conservatives and
Republicans
Mining up to condemn it the difference
is on the left you don't really find
that on the left it's if there are
condom nations now it took a look a
while with with this Ilan Omar stuff
there it took a while some Democrats
eventually did come out and condemn it
took him a while to do it they did it
but depending on the group being
insulted or targeted you may not hear
any condemnation from the left so that's
the difference because you have to keep
in mind that they really do believe this
is their philosophy they believe that
there are certain groups you're allowed
to hate and the hatred is totally
justified and in fact it is impossible
to be bigoted against those groups that
is their that's their philosophy alright
speaking of bigotry here's here's a sort
of a different form of bigotry jussie
Smollett the actor from the show Empire
black man also a gay man I'm sure you've
been following this story he claims it
will just review here briefly he claims
that he was the victim of a racist and
homophobic attack and claims is the key
word here a huge emphasis on claims so
as the story goes he was walking through
downtown Chicago at around 2:30 a.m. one
night several weeks ago and he was then
attacked and brutally beaten he says and
he says the attackers shouted this is
Magga country as they were beating him
in Chicago okay so these are these are
racist whites who are claiming that
Chicago is mega country and they he says
that they called him the n-word and the
F word and so on so fast-forward over
several days police investigate the
attack they find no evidence to support
the claim none at all
Smollett says that he was he was on the
phone at the time of the attack with his
manager and his manager heard
happening so police asked for him to
turn over his phone and he refused for a
while finally he did turn over some
phone records but he redacted them so
heavily as to make them useless police
also checked camera footage
security cameras now as it happens it he
was he was walking down the street at
2:30 a.m. in Chicago in the winter it's
you know extremely extremely cold he was
on his way I think to subway to get a
sandwich and he says that he was
attacked on the way well it just so
happens you're in Chicago major city
there are security cameras everywhere so
his entire trip to Subway is caught on
camera
except for 60 seconds there is just a 60
second gap where cameras don't pick him
up where he's out of sight of cameras
the but all the rest of it there is
there is no you don't see him getting
attacked we don't see the alleged
culprits so he says oh no you know it
just so happens that the attack occurred
in that 60 second gap you know it just
so happens kind of conveniently but we
don't see that he says that he was
beaten to within an inch of his life in
that 60 seconds but then he just
casually got up and walked the subway
anyway and in fact he kept he says that
he was that they poured bleach on him
and that they tied a rope around his
neck and oddly enough he kept the rope
around his neck and went to subway and
then went home and he kept wearing the
Rope because that's what you would do
right if you were attacked with someone
with a rope you would just wear the rope
the whole time he also he didn't want to
call Polly didn't call police he didn't
call you know he didn't go seek medical
help or anything like that eventually
his friends convinced him that he should
call the police and so he did now some
of his neighbors have come out and they
say that they don't believe him
his neighbors point out that they live
in a neighborhood with a lot of gay
people and a lot of minorities and they
live in one of the most liberal cities
in the country so this is one of the
most
liberal towns in one of the most liberal
cities in the entire country
it is essentially the last place on
earth where you would expect to find a
roving group of white racists randomly
attacking minorities in the middle of
the street in the middle of the night
when it's you know negative ten degrees
outside or whatever but of course even
if this happened in like Alabama or
somewhere like that it would still be
extremely far-fetched because even
before you find out that the security
camera footage doesn't capture the
attack and that he didn't turn over his
phone records and all the rest of it
you should still hear that story and
think yeah I don't mmm no I don't think
so I I really I don't think that
happened that just doesn't sound like a
thing that would happen in fact that
sounds like the kind of thing that
liberals make up all the time it doesn't
actually sound like the kind of thing
that really happens though also by the
way we should note that nobody else in
the town has reported an attack like
this but these two culprits if they
existed which they almost certainly
don't but that would mean that they
either just so happened to have a noose
and a bottle of bleach and they happened
to be walking down the street in the
middle of the night when it's freezing
cold outside with a noose and a bottle
of bleach and then they happen to find
this guy and then attack him or they
they took those items and they went out
essentially hunting for a minority or
homosexual to attack but if that's the
case it's very unlikely that this would
be their first time doing it okay you're
not gonna have two guys that just up and
decide one night to go do that this is
you kind of work up to that if you have
someone who is so psychotic and so
racist and violent that they would not
just one person but two people that they
would go out and do that it's probably
not their first time yet there have been
no other reports of anything like that
so the police have have not
yet filed charges against mullet for for
filing a false report I I think it's
pretty pretty clear that if this guy
wasn't a celebrity or if the whole thing
wasn't so politically charged or if he
was a white guy making this claim a
saying that two black men attacked him
you know you know in some sort of racist
attack in any of those scenarios I think
there would already be files there would
already already be charges filed for
filing a false report but in this case
they haven't because I guess you know
it's like 99.999% certain that this is
all made up but there is that sixty
second gap so the police can say that
well technically I mean it could have
happened in that sixty seconds and then
he just casually got up with the rope
around his neck and went got a sandwich
and went home I mean we and then and
then the the two attackers by the way
just vanished into thin air or maybe
they caught they scaled a building or
something like spider-man
and escaped into the shadows I mean it's
possible that that happened so I think I
think basically they're going to need to
find total incontrovertible absolute
evidence that this was invented before
they file those before they charge him
with smollett I mean charge him with a
crime and unless they find video for
that 60 second gap they're not going to
have that kind of evidence so I don't
know so maybe he'll get away with it but
it does it does raise a question of if
this was if this is made up if this is a
hoax which again all signs are pointing
in that direction if it's if it's a hoax
then then what's the point you know why
do people do this kind of stuff and you
do find this on the left rather
frequently usually it's not as elaborate
as this classic classic hoax is usually
involved like a waiter or waitress
claiming that somebody wrote something
racist on a receipt
that kind of thing and then and then
always a couple days later it comes out
that oh no they actually wrote it
themselves so why do they do this and I
think it's pretty clear that there there
are two elements to it
um one is definitely political trying to
paint your political enemies and you
know as as these dangerous lunatics
roving the street looking for minorities
to assault so there's that political
element to it but I think
psychologically even before that it's
just a it's just a ploy for attention
why do people look for attention in that
way you know it's it's hard to know
people that just have a some sort of
hole inside them some sort of emptiness
and and this is how they want attention
I also think that on the left especially
we have to remember that victimhood is
is a painted as a desirable thing
victimhood on the left is power that's
how you have power is if you're a victim
and so there's always this competition
among people on the Left different
groups competing about who is the
greater victim who faces the most
persecution and so I think people are
consortin dition this way and they're
almost soap you know you have this guy's
a he's a Hollywood actor living in a
kind of upscale neighborhood in a in an
urban area
you know I assume he gets paid pretty
well so he lives a pretty comfortable
life and it seems like he's almost
disappointed by that he wants to be a
victim because that's how people are
conditioned by liberals and so he
invents this story alright I want to get
to this this this video is from a couple
of years ago but it's making the rounds
online again and I want to play it
because it is just such a wonderful sort
of distillation of every fallacious
pro-abortion argument it really is
incredible
every single bad pro-abortion argument
just in one video one after another
after another in succession this is a
Bill Nye the fake science guy and he did
this video a couple years ago rambling
on about why he supports abortion and I
just I'm gonna play little things for
you I want you to watch this and then
we'll talk about it but but here it is
if you're gonna say and when an egg is
fertilized it's there for Alma has the
same rights as an individual then who
are you gonna sue Mar you gonna sue whom
are you going to imprison every woman
who's had a fertilized egg pass through
her every guy whose sperm is fertilized
in egg and then it didn't become a human
if all these people failed you
it's just reflection of a deep
scientific lack of understanding and you
literally or apparently literally don't
know what you're talking about
and so when it comes to women's rights
with respect to their reproduction I
think you should leave it to women this
is really you cannot help but notice I
mean I'm not the first guy to observe
this you have a lot of men of European
descent passing these extraordinary laws
based on ignorance I'm sorry you guys I
know it was written or your
interpretation of a book written five
censure of 5,000 years ago 50 centuries
ago makes you think that when a man and
a woman have sexual intercourse they
always have a baby that's wrong and so
to pass laws based on that belief is
inconsistent with nature I mean it's
hard not to get frustrated with this
everybody and I know
nobody likes abortion okay but you can't
tell somebody what to do
I mean she has rights over this
especially if she doesn't like the guy
that got her pregnant like she doesn't
want anything to do with your genes get
over it
especially if she were raped and all
this so it's very frustrating on the on
the outside on the other side we have so
many more important things to be dealing
with we have so many more problems to
squander resources on this argument
based on bad science on just lack of
understanding wow what a fantastic idiot
madonnas two and a half minutes ever
recorded it's it's really incredible yet
as I said it also perfectly represents
the pro-abortion side so so what does
that tell you
alright looks let's run through this so
he begins by conflating abortion with
miscarriage and claiming that pro-lifers
want to put women in jail for having
miscarriages and even says that we want
to put men in jail if they have sex but
fail to conceive yeah because because
that's an argument that we we make all
the time as pro-lifers right but yeah if
you go to the March for Life you'll see
people holding big banners saying put
men in jail for not conceiving children
he then claims that the pro-life side is
a conspiracy among men of European
descent when of course in fact the
pro-life side is at least 50% women if
not more then he says that pro-lifers
base their positions solely on the Bible
and he claims that the Bible was written
5000 years ago which is which is
remarkably stupid even then let's just
focus on that part alone for a minute
he says the Bible was written 5000 years
ago then he says it with such confidence
5000 years ago 50 centuries you think
the whole Bible is written 5000 years
ago no the the oldest
books in the Bible were written maybe
3,000 years ago much of the Old
Testament is far more recent than that
and then of course the New Testament was
was written less than 2,000 years ago so
five and you couldn't be more wrong with
5,000 now I know it seems like I'm
semantics or something but this is a
grown adult man claims to be a scientist
claims to be very knowledgeable he does
these shows where he's instructing
people on all these different subjects
and he thinks the Bible was written 5000
years ago my kids are five years old and
even they know better than that
he then spends a while explaining that
sex doesn't always lead to a baby which
thoroughly debunks a few that literally
nobody holds then he says that nobody
likes abortion which actually the
feminist movement is clear that they are
proud of abortion and they do like it
and finally he gets to his big mike drop
moment the summary of his whole case and
he says you know he's kind of he's kind
of condensing it all down and he says
that well abortion has to be legal
because quote you can't tell somebody
what to do which you can't tell us
that's his argument why should abortion
be legal well because you can't you
can't tell somebody what to do okay well
if that's the case then that means that
we can't have any laws of any kind at
all
you have just undermined law itself
because every law tells people what to
do and what not to do and then at the
end after spending two and a half
minutes torching the most absurd straw
man ever constructed he accuses the
other side of having a lack of
understanding it's it's Wow
but remember something else that you
know as stupid as this is you can't do
much better than that if if you're gonna
spend two and a half minutes trying to
defend killing babies it's not like you
can make a good argument I think you
could be more eloquent and more
coherent than Bill Nye which isn't hard
to do but if we're kind of grading this
on a curve then although it was
supremely moronic we would have to say
that as far as pro-abortion arguments go
it's maybe like a b-minus because there
aren't any good ones anyway
that is just well but the really sad
thing you know we can we can laugh at
how crazy it is but the sad thing is
that there are millions of Americans who
will watch that video and and say oh wow
yeah he really he really debunked the
pro-life position didn't he
wow that was quite a debunking mic drop
there are millions of Americans will see
that and think that it's convincing
they'll be convinced by it
all right well go check the check the
inbox if you want to send a message
email to the show a message email then
you can do that at Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from AJ it says hi
Matt I love your show especially love
when you talk about the historical case
for Jesus ancient manuscripts biblical
history etc considering your interest in
those subjects I was wondering if you'd
seen slash read least robles the case
for Christ I assume you have but I'd be
interested in your take on it
hi AJ yes I I have read it I haven't
seen the movie but I've read the book
now for anyone who isn't familiar the
case for Christ is a really famous
Christian book turned movie written by a
guy named Lee Strobel and the conceit of
the book the framework is that I can't
speak all the same the same beats but I
can't speak to that
so in the book Lee Strobel is a
journalist an atheist journalist who
sets out on this kind of investigation
to discover the truth about Jesus hoping
to disprove Christianity but along the
way he found that Christianity was true
so we converted so the book and movie -
I assume consists mainly of Strobel's
interviews with various New Testament
scholars of street one of the most
famous Christian books written in the
last you know 30 or 40 years and it's
very popular I know a lot of people love
the book this is what I'll say about it
it is a nice devotional book it's it's
nice spiritual reading it's it's good
encouragement for Christians but that's
not how it advertises itself it
advertises itself as a historical
investigation and on that front it fails
so ultimately I didn't like the book
because I think that there's a lot of
false advertising with it and and I
don't really appreciate that I found it
disappointing honestly so I think it's a
well-written book it's an entertaining
book but no I didn't like it here's my
problem with it
Strobel says that he was an atheist
hoping to disprove Christianity okay so
which is which is a great premise I mean
the premise of the book is great that
you get an atheist journalist who wants
to prove that Christianity is wrong so
he goes and he interviews a bunch of
scholars and historians and so on and at
the end of the interview process he
comes to the opposite conclusion and
says oh my gosh
never mind so that's a great premise and
so I love the way the book is presented
I was excited to finally read it because
I thought well that's that's that's
awesome let me read this this book the
problem is that he only interviews
conservative Christian scholars which is
of course totally ridiculous this is
supposed to be an atheist who's trying
to disprove Christianity and he doesn't
interview one single skeptic or secular
historian how can you possibly claim to
be conducting an objective investigation
if you only take talk to one side and
he's supposed to be an atheist while
he's doing these interviews yet an
atheist would only talk to evangelical
apologists he wouldn't take the time to
hear from the other side at all
there are there are I forget how many
interviews it may be a dozen interviews
in the book he doesn't talk to one
single person who's on the other side of
the issue obviously I agree with the
evangelical apologists about the
historical case for Christianity I'm
just saying the book advertises itself
as a sort of objective historical
inquiry and then proceeds to be absurdly
one-sided in fact this is how this is
how bad it gets there's even a chapter
in the book called the rebuttal evidence
and so I'm reading the book and you know
you there there are several Christian
scholars interviewed making their case
and then finally we get to a chapter
called rebuttal and so now I'm thinking
okay this is gonna get good this is
gonna be interesting
this is where he brings in an atheist or
a secular person and has them restore
but everything that he's just learned
and so this is this is gonna be
interesting
except that for the other side for the
rebuttal he interviews an evangelical
apologist instead of getting a secular
historian to tell his own side he has an
evangelical apologist give his version
of the opposing side it so it's it's I
it's ridiculous now I've heard people
justifying this and saying well Strobel
is the skeptic he is the other side so
he doesn't need to talk to someone on
that side he already is so he's
representing that side talking to
Christians but that's not really true
because the whole point is that he
doesn't really know either side he goes
into the investigation not really
knowing anything about the historical
the historical context for Jesus he was
ignorant of the whole issue he knew very
little about it either way so no he
can't represent that side he can't
represent the side of historical of
secular historical experts and scholars
considering he was not an expert or
scholar himself in fact in fact
throughout the book he's constantly
being told basic historical information
things that a lot of us most of us who
aren't scholars know things about like
Josephus and you know and he's told
these things and he reacts with surprise
like it's the first time he's hurted he
didn't know what
for hand now in a real investigation he
would then take that information and go
to the other side and say okay this is
what they're claiming what's your take
I mean imagine a book written by someone
imagine a book with the opposite that
goes the opposite direction imagine a
book written by a Christian a former
Christian claiming that he did an
investigation and talked to experts and
and discovered that Jesus was not the
Son of God so he had a D conversion he
went the other way well imagine if that
book only interviewed atheists imagine
if he never once spoke to a single
Christian expert what would we say about
that book we would laugh at it we would
say well this is just a theists
propaganda obviously the guy knew which
side he wanted to believe beforehand and
he only talked to them so it's the same
thing with this I think it's a
well-written book enjoyable book in some
respects obviously I concur with the
conclusions but I think that it's not
what it bills itself to be and for that
reason it's not going to convince
anything anyone of anything
Christians might find it compelling but
it's not going to convince atheists and
if you talk to atheists about this book
they just laugh at it and they say well
that's you know they make all the points
that I just made in their fair points
anyway and it's really a missed
opportunity I would love to see a book
you know when it comes to this sort of
thing usually you could pick up a
Christian book or you pick up an atheist
book and you're gonna get one side and
then the other I would love to see a
book that kind of goes back and forth
and there's this debate inside the book
between both sides and I think that'd be
really interesting but that's not what
this book is all right from Paul now I
got a bunch of emails I mentioned
yesterday on the show this question of
if you you know a person can survive
with half a brain and so fear and
theoretically its it would be May it
might be possible in the future to do a
brain transplant we can't right now
we're not anywhere close to that but so
the the sort of thought experiment is
imagine if you cuts you cut my brain in
half and transplanted half of my brain
into someone else's body
where did I go you know where is my
consciousness where is my soul in other
words that's the thought I didn't come
up with that thought experiment it was
something that a philosopher proposed a
few decades ago and so I mention le
shell I got a lot of emails about this
and I found it really interesting some
of these emails I'll read a few of them
this is from Paul he says I would think
that the soul follows the right brain we
never hear things like wow that math
equation has a lot of soul but we do
hear that being set up music since art
music and other forms of creative
creative expression originate in the
right brain it would seem that that's
where the soul resides interesting this
is from Stuart he says I've been a
listener reader for several years I
wanted to say thank you for your
boldness and speaking out for what you
believe okay I'll skip over the
compliments although I appreciate them
Stuart anyway I listened to your show
today and had a theory about the brain
transplant thought experiment I'm with
you that I don't think God would let a
soul be divided but I'm also with you
that the response has been of Aqaba my
response to this was the only response I
can think of is is that what you just
you couldn't do it because the human
soul is immutable it can't be divided
and so my my response to you
hypothetically if it were possible my
response is well it could never be
possible which is a which is a bad
response at a total cop-out so he says
ultimately I think your answer is over
emphasizing the role of the brain in
constituting the soul in other words
it's a faulty assumption that the
processes and parts of the brain that
manifest in consciousness are to some
extent the source of the soul but I
think rather than being the source maybe
they're more like the window to the soul
the true you is a separate metaphysical
entity sustained and empowered by the
Spirit of God and experience and
expressed through the filter of you the
body including the brain so speaking
strictly biologically if we think of a
brain as what it really is an organ or
even more generally a machine it's just
a window or a medium through which the
true metaphysical self the you is
expressed in theory if my soul was
connected to somebody else's brain I'd
still be me I just experienced some
different thoughts emotions compulsions
etc all of which are just flavors of the
brain chemistry you possess
just like if my soul was connected to
somebody else's body I may be stronger a
weak
slower or faster but I'd still be me
technically if there was a way to
connect my soul to a toaster I'd still
be me but that would be weird I know
this sounds like it verges on Gnosticism
but I don't think that's the case it's
not the spirit and physical or two
divided on connected realms really the
opposite it's more that the physical
world we live in is just a limited
window through which we interpret the
true spiritual reality and it's also
this is also not to diminish the free
will we do possess but it is to say the
free will our souls possess is certainly
impacted by our bodies brain chemistry
included so back to the question based
on this whole theory my guess is that if
we were to wire the brains together we
wouldn't get a conscious being at all
but both both people would just die in
the resulting Frankenstein monster would
just fire off neurons and put surround
but would never achieve a consciousness
as we understand it in a physical sense
the brain would be able to control the
limbs and move the body but wouldn't
ever possess a will to drive it to
interpret the world and make decisions
this is a much better answer than the
one that I gave I wish I had maybe you
should just do the show Stewart I will
just clarify no I don't think the brain
is the source of the soul at all of
course it's not the source but there is
a it's in in this life anyway
in our mortal realm there is an
inextricable relationship and link
obviously between the body and the soul
and in the mind and I think of the mind
is just sort of another word for the
soul but everything else you said there
I agree with last one this is from patty
I recently watched an episode of the
good doctor in which the face of a girl
who was killed in a car accident was
removed to replace the face of another
girl who had been badly disfigured in a
separate car accident I think that
scenario may help to address the
question you raised about the
irreplaceable 'ti of the soul making it
impossible to transplant one person's
brain with another watching the
transplant and seeing the face of the
one girl on the other was bizarre and
unsettling precisely because it almost
seemed that the living girl was no
longer herself but was taking on the
identity that is the very person of the
dead girl yet the soul being spiritual
is the immutable part of the person
whereas the body being material is
subject to constant change and can be
altered through human intervention such
as transplants even of the face or the
brain
and not constitute the loss of the
person a brain injured person or one in
a vegetative state still has his soul
abiding in his body despite the lack of
normal consciousness so I would think
that even someone with the face or the
brain of another of another person would
remain himself albeit not in the ideal
sense originally intended
that's from Patty a lot of good answer
there were probably dozens of answer to
this all of them much more interesting
than what I offered so I appreciate that
all right we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed